si bernard montiel devait échanger sa
peau contre un chroniqueur je sais c'est
une question pierre annonce franchement
personnes âgées
[Applaudissements]
soit soit un chroniqueur soit une star à
côté voit déjà
non alors il ya un acteur meurt le
connaît peu il s'appelle éric harvey est
autrement moins car ils méritaient film
superman évident et critique de rêve et
en rigueur et en ont fait l'année il ya
cinq ans brad pitt alors j'aurais dit
parce que moi j'aurais voulu être grand
costaud blond aux yeux bleus
quand on voit les trous moqué ici
[Applaudissements]
non c'est pas d'être hugo ils n'ont pas
un physique facile
[Applaudissements]
je vous pourquoi oui parce que nation
afrique solide moi je sais pas c'est à
dire enveloppes et des souris - la
maison de retraite si beaucoup ses bras
cet outil qu'est ce que c'est que cette
tenue encore même vous la meilleure on
vous la donne et j'espère ici c'est
bénéfique si vous mettez quelqu'un
d'autre alors moi je serai johnny peut
être intéressant de savoir ce que être
dans la fin la place d'un homme je
trouve que c'est sympa
ensuite d'être à la place d'un homme et
en plus johnny qui est une bête de scène
chanter comme ça je me vois tellement
que c'est mon rêve
[Applaudissements]
et
c'est tout simplement feint marty s'est
passé une vie différente et tous
excitant voyez ce que je veux dire c'est
que c'est ok sinon au niveau des
chroniqueurs bien sûr je serais à la
place de gilles parce que l'impact maria
déjà une raison et du mal à trouver mes
deux raisons la première c'est que
j'aimerais avoir son talent d'animateur
sur ces news pas comment je serai ce que
ça fait de dire autant de conneries en
deux heures d'émission
[Applaudissements]
alors si je vais être une personnalité
ce serait le comédien jim carrey
j'adorerais avoir son potentiel comique
laissant savoir surtout dans le domaine
demeure où ça va bien merci beaucoup
mais très bien alors on a un peu discuté
bien que rachel bourlier et moi avant
avons un point commun on a eu des
aventures outre atlantique avec le
boulet le montre ce que j'ai vécu et ce
qu'elle a vécu il n'y avait pas de même
plus horaires expérience des bleus merci
de raconter ce que je vous en prie vous
soyez qui a moins je serai leonardo
dicaprio pascal ils défont environnement
il en parle beaucoup mais passe aussi
beaucoup de temps sur des yachts en
serait de même qu'un jour une oreille à
d'elliott
j'ai peur j'ai revu sur des yachts de
top model et on ne lui dit jamais rien
donc moi voilà j'aimerais bien être cet
homme qu'est ce que vous voulez qu'on
lui dise pas écouté quand on défend
l'environnement et qu'on est sur des
bateaux qui polluent c'est quand même ça
fait un petit peu mauvais genre en jet
privé je trouve que j'aimerais bien voir
sa vie puis ont entouré de top model
donc moi je me verrais bien dans la peau
de
moi j tout vous savez nous je partage
tout ce qu'on me dit en fait elle
voudrait dicaprio pour à son zizi coucou
[Applaudissements]
vos légumes m il est toujours entouré de
moi j'aimerais bien ça suffit pas
je vais très très beau et très austère
j'ai pensé au comte dracula corps d un
honneur c'est au tricot bah oui j'ai
voulu me mettre dans un cercueil pour
vivre la nuit comme lui
sa magnifique vous avez beau complément
coface anniversaire de kim shell mais
vous en parler un peu parce qu'elle a
connu des stars internationales et
j'aurais voulu être rachel pourra voir
john law son ancien amant quand même
john loos et anna mais moi je vais plus
loin j'ai plus loin c'est qu'en fait
vous venez de nous avouer que finalement
vous avez sur l'étang var
[Applaudissements]
c'est dur quand même quoi ah oui alors
on a eu du mal avec ce château est la
question
l'édition est simple où en est on avec
le mariage de tous alors avant nous
marchions vers la gloire maintenant nous
combattons vers la loi est aussi proche
on est à sa belle gaffe on est bon à la
défaite quand même daniel moreau alors
mais ce soir je vous promets depuis
maintenant quelques semaines peut-être
ce soir on aura un cadeau pour vous à
savoir un calendrier de garçons ils font
du libye alors si je bats si je prenais
la peau enfin le corps d'un chroniqueur
c'est intéressant ça de voir comment ça
va et ce serait bernard parce que c'est
quand même le star fucker auto
[Applaudissements]
j'aimerais bien prêt comme jamais elle
était dans des courses et rentrer nana
elle est au courant de mes tongs
alors il fait de mal non non pas du tout
personne dans ma vie j'ai avec mon chien
[Applaudissements]
la voix d'or était main dans la main ces
langues dans la langue
excusez moi voilà oui mais n'a pas eu
pénétration sinon une pipe à m
j'aimerais vraiment derrière
monica bellucci pour voir ce que ça fait
de fantasmer tous les mecs juste ouais
voilà c'est bien regarder dans
différentes finales aller au bout et
mener carrière s'est passée à ça doit
vraiment rien si on a le droit d'y en a
pour tous vraiment à bout j'ai vraiment
depuis quelques semaines
j'ai passé mes camarades sont d'après
votre visage est en train de changer
ah je sens que le chroniqueur accompli
que vous êtes devenu passe beaucoup de
temps en boîte de nuit parce que
maintenant on a un point commun c'est
que vos yeux il ce coffret
ils sont perdus je pars d'ici de 10h30
11h du soir et je rentre dans le cas
mais les 88 du matin je dors pas bien
mais le temps que je monte en loge
défourailler tout le buffet qui reste là
au moins on people je prendrais n'ont
donc pas besoin d'eau pour sa vie cent
mille dollars au soleil
itinéraire d'un enfant gâté le
professionnel tout ça le foot la boxe
les voitures les femmes toute la vie
qu'il a eues j'aurais aimé avoir sa vie
donc voilà c'est pour en people c'est
belmondo et en chroniqueur c'est bernard
montiel parce qu'il est comme tout le
monde il connaît qui connaît les
puissants il connaît les stars
il connaît tous les points soleil d'île
de france on sait tout le temps beau
pour le prix monte hier c'est beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
mois ci c'est au tour de la table je
sois dit vous parce que vous mettriez
vous connaissez mon rêve c'est de me
marier et vous vous l'avez fait plein de
fois
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
seuls quatre mariages en a bien un que
j'aurais aimé vivre
je pense donc et donc oui alors voilà
c'est quelqu'un de connu j'aurais aimé
donner je suis parce que moi je suis
inconnu
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
voilà maintenant si c'est quelqu'un qui
passe voilà castaldi ne m'écoutait la
raison vous avez fait combien de mary
barry iv qui n'arriva oui et si vous
remarquez une cinquième à cendras ainsi
dire que vous avez choisi le maire qui
comprenait au hasard à chaque fois
palmer de la ville at war il pensait
femmes au hasard
[Rires]